welcome back to Piers Morgan says the
massager of trans athletes competing in
women's sport appears to be nearing what
I would say is a common sense conclusion
at least for now images like this a
transgender swimmer Leah Thomas that we
discussed earlier kind of crystallize
the absurdity in our fairness well
certainly that's what I think well high
profile stories of Laurel Hubbard who
made the Tokyo Olympics as a trans
weightlifter at the age of 43 nearly
double the age of any of the other
female contestants spot Furious debate
well last week World Athletics announced
that trans athletes will no longer be
allowed to compete against women from
the end of this month they did it to
protect fairness and integrity of
women's sport critics said it's
transphobic that's their response to
anything in this in this debate and
leaves trans women with nowhere to go
which is a fairer argument which has to
be resolved but joining me now is
British shot by Champion Emilia
strickler and human rights campaigner
Peter tatchel welcome to both of you
um Amina we had you on before about this
and you were very passionate about why
this needed to happen so I'd imagine you
you've really been pleased to see this
development 100 we're a lot of women
especially in athletics are really
really excited about this it's just
about now making it go into Grassroots
and Masters level where there is a lot
of trans women competing in the women's
category as well so now that we've got
the elite level it needs to be all
levels all sports so Peter it's complex
this because I don't want trans athletes
not to be able to compete let me just
say that straight away but I spent some
time with Martina navratal over in
Florida last week who's been recovering
from double cancer and it's very moving
interview but we actually had a chat
about this as well because she's one of
the most high profile lgbtq campaigners
has ever been And yet when she raised
her head over the parapet about this and
said I just think it's a real problem
and you can't allow this to continue
otherwise women's sport will be
destroyed she then got tried to be
canceled and people abused her they
shamed her and so on which I thought was
completely ridiculous the idea she's not
a friend of the transgender Community
because she's trying to stand up for
what she saw was and fairness for
women's rights in spool and I just
thought that was terrible what what do
you make of this ruling by Sebastian Co
and what Athletics and how do we resolve
all this well the first principle is
that sport has to be fair
and it's not fair if people have
particular unique advantages so you
would accept that well I accept that but
I would also accept that not all trans
athletes are the same so some may have
an advantage and others may not so for
example I know a woman a trans woman who
competes in a women's football team I'm
on the team she is one of the smallest
and weakest of the team no one can say
that she has an unfair advantage and
equally all athletes in Elite Sports
have some kind of Advantage they may
have extra large lungs or Hearts A Long
Legs tall height Michael Phelps that
fantastic brilliant swimmer who won so
many gold medals in the pool had it on
feasibly large wingspan yeah and right
when he put his arms out it was six
inches longer than anybody else's
reached so but he also had extra large
lung capacity right so I've heard such
feat yeah I I think you know it's not an
invalid argument I mean they're you know
in All Sport you're going to get some
people who are physical freaks if all of
a better phrase like Michael Phelps who
literally could do this and it's
normally the same as your height or
something isn't it the span and you had
six inches extra massive hands right
obviously you can help him in huge feet
I think as well what's what's your
response to that argument but
biologically they're still the sex that
they're competing against
um you know at the end of the day
reducing a testosterone level is is not
going to cut it because women are so
much more than a testosterone level you
know physiologically you know periods
whole other whole other well that is
certainly not to be you know it's we're
so much more than a testosterone level
so just reducing a testosterone level at
the end of the day I mean it's not going
to change the physiological difference
there's a lot of these people too are
you know they're training as a male
athlete for a long period of time before
transitioning so they're having
lung capacity as well all these things
which you get after having gone through
puberty they're real things which give
most most trans athletes a an immediate
biological advantage that's my problem
the other half of this is what what if
if they don't compete against women born
to female bodies what happens to trans
athletes now I think there's one of two
things you can do either they compete
against their biological sex which most
of them have done anyway for many years
is actually never successfully against
women which I think is the argument
right there or you create an entirely
new category there are more and more as
you said at Grassroots level you create
an entirely new category for Trans
athletes to compete against other trans
athletes well my starting point is there
shouldn't be a blanket ban on all trans
athletes there should be individual
assessment so where there are issues
that's never going to work as well no of
course it can you can't make it one you
know person by person by person by
person you can't they're not that many
trans athletes overall and it's quite
fear actually there are more and more of
them well there are but there's still a
very thirteen in Elite Athletics DSD
athletes so 13 Elite as you see what my
issue with this they're going to start
breaking women's records irrevocably
because I mean Leah Thomas won One race
against females that's just a point of
the argument females by 50 odd seconds I
mean it was ridiculous and then at the
podium Tower is over these these this
Podium picture you can't no one can be
happy about that yeah that is clear
Advantage for a biological male what I'm
saying where there is a clear
demonstrable proven Advantage an unfair
Advantage then of course that should not
be allowed to take place but I do think
that individual assessment rather than a
blanket ban is the way to go okay
because then you you don't you penalize
the ones who do have an unfair Advantage
but you don't penalize that ones that
don't so Amelia it's interesting because
in in rugby I think in places like New
Zealand now for example they do actually
because they recognize that some kids
when they get to 13 are twice the size
of other 13 year old kids they now
separate them in weight classes rather
than age so they put the ones who are a
certain size and they they play rugby
against each other depending it's no
longer about age
so it's what Peter says he's got any
Merit to do it this way I mean I I I I
don't think me or many female athletes
would think that was still appropriate
because of the biological sex that is
there at the end of the day yeah there's
still so many physiological differences
they're not going to have you know
they're never going to have a period
right whereas every Elite female athlete
once a month has but in some cases quite
a crippling condition which they're
going to get every month which will
affect their training will affect
confidence competitions right which I I
completely understand when women say
that that's not going to happen to a
trans athlete no it won't so they have
that Advantage regardless of their size
yeah but again I say
don't have a blanket ban have individual
assessment I think it's particularly
unfair for intersex athletes like Casa
semenya well that's a different case but
but it's very similar because it's about
you know a mixture of male and female
and it's not something they have chosen
it's something I do feel I I feel it's
not like the the rapist situation
Scotland where I think they're literally
scamming the system I do have respect
for people who transition it's not about
being transphobic at all it's about
Caster didn't transition she was born no
I know I know I I think that's a
different case but I I think that
they're very very unique cases I mean
there's hardly any of them right well
there's the 13th that's the number in
terms of Casa smart DSD yeah sorry that
was the number I I was referring to 13
DSD athletes in the women's distance
events and three of them had
gold silver and bronze in 2016 Olympics
so I mean we're you know clearly they
have an advantage because they've done
really really well for themselves well
they might just be very good athletes
but you know I I take them there's a
debate going on here yeah and I think we
need more science more investigation and
I do think as I said it has to be fair
for World Athletics said we've seen the
science this is why we've made our
decision we've seen the science Peter I
like your attempt to try and win this
argument but I think I don't agree even
Lord codes said he did Even though kohe
said it's not proven that they don't
have an advantage so you know it's it's
a negative that Lord Co and the world
Athletics Federation are seeking to
uphold and I think that's a very bad way
to go maybe but I think the best way to
do is to is to say stop pause continue
investigating but for now preserve the
Integrity of women's sport right I mean
I mean that's where I think please give
us a shot yeah please and your case
literally literally yes uh great to talk
to you both thank you both very much